my first question Kanye West this week
has said I'm a bit sleepy tonight but
when I wake up I'm going Defcon 3 on
Jewish people will Israel retaliate
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
know
anti-Semitism is the longest uh hatred
in history it goes back
thousands of years we've dealt with
bigger problems than than these
stupidities but you know the Communists
blame the Jews for being capitalists the
capitalists blame the Jews were being
communists you have a problem blame the
Jews it's old stuff it shouldn't have
any place in civilized discourse and
that's the reason we establish the
Jewish state so the Jewish people would
have defense against
these absurdities and sometimes they're
coupled with violence we don't let that
happen again
okay
um
I just want to read a few quotes from
American Congressman just to Congress
people rather just to to show that uh
Kanye's West is uh Kanye West's comment
is not really out of order with some
things that are said by people in more
official positions uh here's one Israel
has hypnotized the world may Allah
awaken the people and help them see the
evil doings of Israel ten years ago if
you read that to me I thought that would
be from Hezbollah that's an American
Congress person another American
congressperson says the reality of
Israel's apartheid government goes on to
say the occupation and ethnic cleansing
Palestinians live with every day another
one says Israel it targets media sources
so the world can't see Palestinians
being massacred I have three questions
for you are you massacring Palestinians
are you ethnic cleansing and are you an
apartheid state
no no and no I mean these are all
ridiculous uh charges against the one
democracy in the Middle East
the one democracy that upholds human
rights that defends freedom and is
America's best ally so I think these
people should
wake up to reality but I think that's a
a far too great a hope it's not going to
happen we just have to defend ourselves
against these people because they purvey
lies you ever hear the word uh fake news
this is fake old news goes back
thousands of years we're not impressed
by it
okay
um
what could you become an apartheid state
the the critics of Israel here in
America and some in your own country uh
talk about the fact that Israel is kind
of a population time bomb and that if 51
of Israel would become Arab because you
do have Arab citizens who are actually
treated better in Israel with more
rights and more freedoms than they are
in their own and other Arab countries uh
but if 51 percent of Israel became Arab
then you would have to become an
apartheid state is that something that
you think about as much as your critics
do
because I think they don't have the
facts right I mean the they're about 20
of Israel's population is Arabs and
they're really the only Arabs uh in the
Middle East to enjoy full and equal
Civic rights and in the Israeli
democracy and I've also made it an
effort
to incorporate them into tremendous
success story that is Israel and I'm
happy to see that that is happening but
the demographic balance is maintained
the most important thing is the
Democratic balance is maintained because
everyone has a right to be part of the
Israeli democracy and the Israeli uh the
Israeli success tour I don't think
that's a real issue I think it's a it's
a bogus charge and especially at bogus
charge that's coming from the
Palestinians who oppress gays oppress
women and are in League with Iran Iran
which is uh tormenting its citizens
suppressing women there and if I have to
say anything the place where they should
direct their fire is it the Iranian
regime and they should support the brave
women of Iran that are showing the world
what courage is that's where it is and
that's where I am I'm supporting the
people of Iran
[Applause]